hello there reject nation I woke up
about 25 minutes ago I was preparing for
movie fights very late last night I'm
gonna go on there later today did you
see my announcement for Bill and Ted
three and I'm the rules of being a
hitman - yeah where's this going to this
in there right Jeff wafer for 25 minutes
[Music]
a toast okay
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
that's gonna be one oh [ __ ] it's gonna
coolest fights
[ __ ] hi max oh that's fantastic but the
thing is if you text that number after
that our people will try to kill you
make sure you know it's hidden
I am so flipping excited for this movie
man yeah I was just thinking in the
shower last night because as I am where
I do most of my thinking you know like
he's so cool they did John wick for and
they brought carrie-anne moss in there
and then they hit directly rated yeah
man that was awesome and I also love how
he and McShane looks like he's doing the
same exact thing he's doing in lions
gates Hellboy movie Ian McShane is kind
of like Ben Mendelsohn to me lately
where he has been typecast in in this
kind of role he's like sort of a mentor
a teacher and he's you know suave and
elegant but also kind of shady that's so
cool that uh Mark Dacascos Dacascos is
Mark do Costco mark de Casas de castas
he's got a pretty big following and I
I'm not part of that big fall but I've
seen him in enough stuff that where I
see him I'm like okay he's pretty cool
dude it's and I like that they're
setting him up to be a worthy villain
here you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
and how they bury looks pretty cool to
film - yeah her I love the additions
here I mean her and Angelica Houston -
I'm excited to see her do more than this
waking up to this is the best way to
wake up in the morning yeah because this
is also - like this trailer is just such
a symphony of action like you know we
all know there's gonna be the story he's
trying to evade you know all the people
were trying to kill him but really I
mean I think they know that yeah we're
just waiting for the barrage of
inventive action scenes in like yeah
that hallways I always firework yeah
because it's up east side of him there's
a display of weapons weapons to choose
from so what does that
moment worries like throw this is like
to shoot at him and then throw a knife
that looks so freaking cool the way he
did that guys I just got imagine them
both of the guys in this hall we're
getting itchy they're like their weapons
already I grabbed one we don't even have
to fight that's good I feel like the
hand-to-hand combat here is gonna be so
unbelievably uh you unique and/or better
too
compared to the first two John wick
films and that motorcycle fight sequence
oh yeah swords have have we seen
anything like that like I haven't seen
anything like that maybe in some type of
Asian cinema yeah there but at least in
US cinema I I cannot recall though one
time I've seen a fight like that
wanna bet Chad still ski would be really
psyched to hear you say that because you
know that that's part of their goal with
these movies is just to bring you know
inventive and unique action you know
amid a landscape that has you know sort
of us as type of action you know like
there's a lot of shaky unintelligible
stuff out there that's pretty you know
like hard you know MMA based almost hard
hard walk and this is you know I feel
like part of the point of John wick is
being inventive and showing us you know
parts of action that we haven't seen as
much in American cinema yeah and so you
know I imagine that if that's happened
it would have come from some kind of
Hong Kong film or something with with
what the trailers the last two I've
noticed I've been using a lot of like
that classical kind of music and you
know and here you do see like an image
of it look the way they trailer cut him
in the way he was going to a castle
where Harold Halle Berry was yeah now
I've just come to assume that everybody
every like major character in this
universe lives in some kind of majorly
picturesque place yeah well you see like
if you break it it looks like they're
traveling a hell of a lot yeah it looks
like they're in New York looks like
they're in Japan it looks like he
survives the one hour yeah Eddie and it
looks like they're in like some kind of
bizarre in like the Middle East or
something yeah I wonder if that the
dollar Lee's with the dogs yeah and I
wonder if that correlates to that shot
where he's a little walk
the Dune you know like if that's before
after that or something right right
right
because yeah it definitely seems like
they're gonna hunt him all across the
world
I really want this 14 million dollars
what were they coat the high high high
table the high table and they had a high
table I feel like we're gonna actually
see the high table in this one mm-hmm
and it really is just a very tall table
yeah the guys these channel all grab
voice it's gonna be like Zordon gonna be
in a to like Power Rangers is gonna be
Bryan Cranston again alright guys well
are you excited for John Luke chapter 3
I sure AM subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell and check
us out on patreon we do weekly Q&A TV
show reactions stream along some one
reaction highlights included and music
video coverage would love to have you
come up a project today
oh yeah I wanted even pitch in the day
shout out to a man named Curt Anderson
today Curt Anderson you guys might have
heard mention him before he is one of
our senior citizen patrons 95 years old
and still looking sharp as ever and he's
one of our top reward to your patrons
and he doesn't his rewards your requests
allows him to request videos and then we
should cover whatever he requests
anything and he he doesn't he just he
just likes to throw money around like
it's nothing and I like a guy who can
wipe his ass with money meet friends
like that they'll get you a lot further
in life than you realize people and we
need a video of you doing that Curt just
that's the one will react to uh-huh and
I feel like he's the most appropriate
one to shout in on John wick like Keanu
Reeves who doesn't seem to ever age
despite the fact that he is technically
getting older and also Curt Anderson is
someone who's constantly traveling the
world apparently like John wick as well
are you on the run are you an assassin
are you okay are you going into surgery
have you been to the high table have you
ever visited a Vietnamese prison yeah
you ever seen a grown man naked these
are important questions that we have
completely improvised on the spot but
Curt I just want you to know that I like
you
some days I love you other days I'm
jealous of you which means we're right
in the middle at all points and you turn
me on a hundred percent of the time all
right well now this video is done